hey wassup guys my name is Jenna welcome
to episode 56 of game programming so
last time we took a look at a fairly you
know non efficient way to actually
handle loading tiles and boss loading
levels and we got this sort of result
where um what level works but it's just
a really messy way of doing it and we
did actually end up loading that level 4
file and one thing you might have
noticed actually actually is that I'm
using a different microphone I'm using
like a head I'm using my headset mic
just cause it's a lot easier to you know
to move around I guess and to to
actually you know make videos with it if
they're live commentary just because
there isn't some massive thing in front
of me obscuring the screen so I'm in my
office if this sound quality is variable
if it is then I'll just continue using
this and it'll be a lot easier for me
anyway back to this so we're just gonna
get rid of basically all this I just
wanted to show you guys that method just
for fun but you're not really gonna be
using it that much so get tile want to
use this method so what we've got going
on right now is is this generate level
thing it kind of generates a level right
but instead of actually looking up a
certain thing here we want to sort of
transfer this level pixel thing into
here so how is that gonna work how is
that gonna work that's sort of the big
thing here how is it going to work so
the way that is actually going to work
is pretty simple we're gonna basically I
should probably change that to tiles
eventually but we've already got this
tile so first of all to go back into
level and delete our tile tiles
alright so our array of tiles will
disappear and when we do that so in
other words we don't really need this
generate a general method anymore
alder overhears will actually reef after
that so if you right click hit hit
refactor and then rename or you could
just hit alt shift art that works as
well um and was called tiles just so
that um we don't get confused so now
we've got this tiles thing you know we
need to basically find a way to I guess
read it all right
now because they've got a subclass to it
I'm just thinking about how I'm gonna do
this best way to do it is probably going
to be to somehow import this tiles level
into it now one advantage that we
actually have straight away is that we
can only have one level loaded at once
and that sort of makes that sort of
makes me thinks right away all right
well if we can only have one level
loaded at one time it makes sense that
there's just a global variable in the
level class that handles the actual
level data right I mean if we go if we
can only have one level loaded then we
just need one variable so I'm gonna make
a protected int tiles called
just rights right over here and it's
going to be an array as well of tiles
and this is going to contain all the
level styles so if you think about it
this way this this array is going to
contain the color values of every level
so another over of every pixel on that
level so in other words if I actually
find my the image took me a minute to
find the image all right here we go so
if I actually open up this level you'll
see that we have different colors right
and that integer is actually going to
store their different colors of it's
going to store this entire image as a
pixel array right some otherwise it will
store location of every pixel as well as
its color so it'll have a bunch of
indexed integers which contain the color
of every pixel you see here which we can
then use to actually generate and
display our level now think of it this
way because we can only have one level
lower at one time this tiles thing is
going to contain the tiles of the level
that is currently loaded all right so
that when we actually go to get tile
over here we'll actually just be able to
say that if tiles X plus y times width
equals a certain color so in other words
in our case if we actually already
deleted this but we've still got the
room
these things let me just adjust these
values quickly because remember they
were actually like this right
we know the grass is dark color so we
can just say if that is equal to this
then we'll return tailed or grass if let
me just cut and paste this over here
because the multiple levels will contain
these same tiles so obviously you know P
of a um I don't know P up like a spawn
level and like a forest biome let's just
say they're gonna that they're both
gonna possibly have grass tiles right so
that's why we're gonna just make this
guitar method up in the level class in
the superclass of all the other
subclasses so we know that we also know
that let's just say flowers or flowers
that color right and then rock is this
color awesome and then we don't find
anything will return a void tail and
avoid a crash so let's get rid of that
now now that we have that we're all
mapped in here and we've got everything
going on actually I'll keep that there
didn't get out of other things you guys
might like some annotated code okay well
awesome so now that I've got this we
need a way to actually set tiles equal
to that and the best way to do that is
probably to just get rid of this really
and we've got a private in here called
tiles fur get rid of that you'll see
that we don't get any errors in the rich
book we don't get an error it's because
we're we're referring to the super class
tiles integer array integer all right
just an array of integers awesome so
right now let's go ahead and check out
what we get all right so now similar to
the other thing we get a blue screen and
it looks like we're nowhere to be found
in the level now few reasons could be
causing that first of all blue screen
means that well maybe there's a bunch of
oil so trains are probably none of these
things are actually adding up correctly
so let's take a look at this
so we're scanning through all of these
and it looks like when we try and get
the tile which is what we're trying to
do and render it then what the most
common thing here well first of all
actually a list is room
finish replacing that and see if that
does anything all right now because the
player is supposed to start at zero zero
the most common thing that probably went
wrong here is that we didn't actually
set the tiles right so in other words
we've got this tiles variable but it's
not set to anything and spawn level but
sort of put it to new int but you can
see that our generator level is actually
empty and the way that we can do that is
basically you see that this tiles
variable does actually have a bunch of
colors
you know attributed to it so in other
words we've put colors into this tile
variable so in other words let's just in
generate level let's just take a look at
something right let's just say let's
print tiles plus tiles and I don't know
we'll just print tile number zero right
so in other words that is really the top
left most tile so we get a color right
let's actually it's a negative color
which immediately tells me that it's got
alpha alpha support in it which is good
that's great
because you can see here that we
actually need some alpha support I out
the front for everything else to work so
now now we can let's just try we'll
actually know that that basically tells
us that the works right away so we've
already got a color attributed to it the
only thing is it's not showing up now so
why isn't it showing up first of all
let's just diagnose its quickly by
saying if the problem is this and if it
is this then okay it is that so in other
words this method is never being run it
seems that were always
okay so it seems trite away to me that
this is this is how men solve coding
problems so it seems that yeah okay so
it seems that this is constantly an
issue yet and that's fine it seems that
there's something wrong with this card
all right so obviously this card is
constantly being ran because it seems
that for some reason for some reason our
X is actually us in zero why is it less
than zero our X is greater than or equal
to width or our Y is wearing ankle to
height is always being around us so why
is that happening there's a cliffhanger
for you guys sitting work this one out
later guys
you